recurrence relations right we've
introduced them now so see weekly we
introduced them after integration by
parts right why did we do that why now
why did it make sense together trust me
I do this all the time now
serious question integration by parts
and then recurrence relations do you
remember like that was not just an
accident like we could do any orderly
line
what is it the link is you guys my part
we the recurrence relations what's the
point
yeah sort of okay can we can we recite
what is the definition of integration
part the integral of U DV is equal to UV
minus 1 the integral of V du u ok now
the whole idea is that integration by
parts works but introducing another
integral right now therefore if this
integral looks anything like what you
started with all right and we noticed
that there were some examples like trig
functions like high powers of X and so
on where that occurred you get an
integral in terms of another integral
that's similar to itself and that's why
we talked about this recurrence ok so
let me see if I can time that up
recurrence relations flow naturally out
of integration by parts ok so therefore
it can be tempting when you'll sort of
in this recurrence relations sub topic
right it's tempting to use integration
by parts for everything right um it's
that all saying when you're holding a
hammer everything looks like a nail
ok but it's not always a good idea to
use integration by parts let's just do a
very simple example just to illustrate
it ok so
this down underneath way you've got your
heading I will give you a simple
integral and I hope for your sake you
can all see what it is and that you
don't need integration by parts right if
this is what we were asked to work with
okay and I actually gave a similar
example to some of you last lesson okay
we do not need to do this by parts right
what would be a more sensible way to do
this I should use substitution right
what should I introduce as my
substitution it would be the inside
function hasn't worked right so this is
really a clever use of reverse chain
rule but I'm just gonna write about that
gives you do you on DX as 3x square cuz
the one just vanishes right and now you
can substrate it it's very simple right
if I call this Phi I is going to be
equal to the 3x squared of the DX they
become out do you not change it very and
what you're left with is this no big
deal now just for the sake of
illustration let's consider what would
happen if you gave this a go but thought
aha
it looked look into products this times
this integration by parts maybe okay
let's see what happens what would you do
okay what would you choose is U and what
would you choose is DV there's an
obvious choice think about it
you want Divi to be easy to integrate
don't you which of these is easier to
integrate 3x squared so you'd make this
your DVD you make this you okay so in
that case what's do you want DX do it
together I mean that's gonna be 3x
squared you've got a 9 that's gonna be
27 x squared times 1 X cubed plus 1 to
the power of 8 okay I've got my DNA of
debts
I need my fee obviously we chose it
because that was easy to integrate so
you just get X cubed right okay so let's
see what happens when you do this this
integral I instead of this what are we
gonna end up with you're going to get u
v
there's UV I'm going to take away the
integral of V du u on I sound right 27 X
to the 5 X cubed plus 1 to the 8th DX
not only have you not solved it
integration by parts is one of the only
methods you've got where when you go
further in this sometimes what you end
up with is dramatically worse
what's the degree of these things that's
that's gonna give you twenty four twenty
degree 29 yeah cool
well let's expand okay this is a bad
idea you can see why easy examples okay
you don't you shouldn't necessarily lead
to integration by parts